[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm red and I'm
length this week at my dining table and
the illustrious card table in the
creative house where Rhett I see your
city yes we once again yes once again we
are going to we're gonna dive into a
number of topics that you have dictated
in response to a prompt that we put out
across the universe I mean when you put
prompts out there it's like hey guys you
have any questions for us
I wonder if aliens are like tempted to
respond you know it's like if there are
aliens with a capacity to monitor
everything we're doing are they a man I
really want to respond and if they do
could they be using an alias as one of
these people I don't we can assess
though from a physical limitation
standpoint if they wanted to respond I
mean the best technology that we have at
this point can only move information at
the speed of light so if they do respond
it's gonna be years from now and it will
be irrelevant now if they are here ohoho
you're assuming that they have the
limitations that we have well no I mean
they may be here in some form or fashion
or they may have a way to monitor us
even from a distance in a way that we
don't so and it also communicates with
us
yeah instantaneously yeah my mind's
really in in the world of aliens because
even though I you know I read the
three-body problem then I read then I
read the sequel dark forest and then I
was like you know what this is this is
too bleak and this too heady and it's
too much I can't do it and then I
realized that I've been paying for
audible and I had forgotten that I
should listen to some audio audiobooks
you said listen to books while you
you're walking around the neighborhood
I'll say I should give that a try and so
I downloaded the third book the final
book in the trilogy of a little been
listening to that it may I mean I can
walk for a long time like I'm walking
like over
our cuz I'm I'm just walking as a way to
listen to a book I don't even know where
I am
yeah and you get so many more books and
I use the term read I don't care
I see what somebody says I don't specify
I'm listening to a book I'm like I'm
reading a book because I mean Who am I
I'm not a guy who listens to books no
actually I am and I've gotten through so
many more books than normal
do you think because I've been walking
so much do you walk slower or faster
when it gets more intense or is it
irrespective irrespective I walk more
like what you're saying you know I want
to keep listening in fact last night
I finished a book that was great and it
just one sent me like five days of
walking to finish what book so it's
pretty short book it's called the
stranger in the woods you member we did
that I would have made this a wreck if
in a subsequent episode so now you're
stealing it from me but the we did that
episode on GMM about Hermits and our
weird people I don't know what it was it
was back in the day and we taught about
the North Pond hermit yeah who lived
next to that lake in Maine and was
isolated by himself with no human is
what isolation means except for one to
be isolated with people I guess except
for one interaction in 27 years and he's
thought to be the person who was the
most isolated person in human history
potentially which i think is what we
titled the video back when we did those
type of news it's an incredible story of
a journalist who wanted to track and
interact with this guy no no no it's
after he got arrested and what and you
know because he was stealing from
everybody right it's I was like why is
this book rated so highly
you know that's and then I well I
learned by reading it aka listening to
it because it's an incredibly
introspective like the journalist is
very introspective and the way that he
explores the concept of isolation
and Hermitage if that's a word hmm it's
only like a six hour listen and it's a
good time to read it you know when
you're like you're trying to gain some
sort of what's the word like a
perspective no like a connection to this
guy who's done this there's camaraderie
like hey I'm not alone in this ceiling
his level of isolation the funny thing
is is not at one point during the book
did it strike me that I was doing
anything remotely close to what this was
good this guy was doing did that nobody
or was it it still matter no it didn't
matter it it's just he's touching it's
touching in fact Wow at the end like I'd
walked for four and a half miles last
night listening to this book and I was
coming up to my house and I was like I
don't really want to I can look at my
I'm listening to the book on my watch I
don't even have my phone it's just my
watching my my headphones and I I'm like
there's 15 minutes late and I just went
in if 15 minutes left I went and sat on
my front steps and then I just began to
weep really during this there's a moment
at the end where oh don't spoil it
where it will make you cry if you have a
heart well what do you mean you don't
know if I have a heart I'm saying for
all the people out there not everybody
cries at everything Brett no one's
listening to this conversation yeah it's
just me and you man and I do have I'm
not talking about that I was gonna make
it a wreck for later because I know I
Ranger in the woods the stranger in the
woods I think it's called so where do
you what are you land right now on
podcast versus audiobooks and how are
you navigating that because I know you
like listening to podcast too and if you
get on a good series yeah and see from
thinking about it my thing is always
about like am I gonna listen to music
because I'm you know or am I gonna
listen to a podcast and now it's am I
gonna listen to an audio but I think
audiobook has taken the place of podcast
for me at the at this
moment yeah well you know for some
reason because I've list I'd listen to
podcast a lot I listen to them
especially while driving I was already
listening to a lot of audiobooks but
slowly audiobooks have sort of pushed
podcast out but it's an interesting
dynamic because I also listen to I don't
listen to music when I work out most
people do most people need some kind of
music and I understand that some BPM is
baby but I'm just like I kind of want
what I get from the book or from the
podcast more than I want the feeling
that the music gives me when I'm working
out and some books can get too complex
to listen to while you're like present I
mean you have to be new you have to be
embodied to really work out because if
you're as opposed to walking I think
that I think he could be dangerous but I
do both I still do more audiobook
listening while working out then podcast
but I find that podcast because they're
they're just sort of a light-hearted
conversation most of the time you can
kind of tune it into now and it is
better for working out but I can't count
to 10 like I couldn't count reps and
listen to the book I'm listening to I
mean it's a very complex book and I'm
not that complex of a guy so I really
got to apply myself if I had to count to
10 three times in a row I couldn't do it
it which it which reminds me of
meditation you know this is it there's a
thing of meditation where it's like you
count your breaths and when you get to
10 you start over most the time I don't
ever get to 10 the first time you know I
definitely couldn't it's very difficult
I don't I don't want to be trying to do
my reps anymore sometimes I'll find
myself in the teens and I mean like oh
you're supposed to start over yeah that
happens sometimes dude because you can
count you can have it on autopilot
unless you do it but you in two quick
things though two quick things before we
get into that all the time you need
first thing is I want to acknowledge the
fact that this is very likely
you know unforeseen circumstances
notwithstanding fingers crossed that we
will do the podcast separate right so we
actually alas break the screen can break
this to you your biscuits here because
you're gonna find out tomorrow anyway if
you listen to this when it comes out but
we actually went back into the studio
you of us this comes out Monday along
with the episode there at the same time
Oh
again Monday not on Sunday so no one's
anything out yeah
so the the episode of GMM that you could
watch today if you're listening to this
on Monday when it comes out you'll see
that it's just it's me and Lincoln
Stevie in the studio because the three
of us have been in quarantine and we
have determined that it is safe for us
to get together and shoot the show
together and that's the way we're gonna
do it until we hear further information
that will allow us to bring in a few
more people and social distance and
masks and all that stuff so along with
that we will be going back into the ear
biscuits to do with the roundtable of
dim light so the echo that you hear
especially on my side will be gone the
USB audio quality which I've seen some
audio files actually complain about
because we're using these USB mics
that'll be gone we're going XLR all the
way all the time
mm-hmm so we'll be back to the way it
should be and we can mentally tell you
don't forget about that that's the
biggest part we can smelly did I let you
mentioned that we can see each other
directly firstly no delay through snow
delights and and we have shot so
yesterday we went in and we shot a few
episodes of GMM with Stevie and it was a
joy was it not yeah I mean yeah I was I
mean I think I said it in one of the
episodes that like I was very I had our
attempt sleeping the night before
because I was so excited about it but I
was also nervous because it was just the
three of us in charge of a
a lot of technical things but Morgan
Morgan had set up this amazing system
with GoPros covering the space and
shooting the the Settings panel on like
the the audio output and different and
we're Stevie would sit and kind of
control and maintain all of these things
and so they were all on Morgan and the
rest of the crew that was needed for all
the episodes they were monitoring live
and communicating with us even though we
were the only three feet
we were the six hands for the who knows
how many people were watching in
addition of five camp like our
traditional five camera setup running at
the same time our audio feed coming from
the mic and being monitored by Chris our
audio guy who was watching a video feed
of just the waveforms or that just the
audio kit basically yeah it was an
incredible system and and it was
dimension it to the crew we said it to
the crew but it was like they one of the
things that we've said multiple times is
how easy they make it for us when we're
in the studio yeah well they actually
made it easy for us when they weren't in
the studio now there was a lot of like
moving parts and cleaning up and stuff
that we normally don't have to worry
about yeah but it was still I mean
you'll be able to see when you see these
episodes next week's episodes which is
still just three a week for now you can
say today's episode yeah this week's
episode there's a joy you were had with
that yeah gospel joy had it was done I
was so relieved that the system worked
and then we got you know there was a
couple of hitches at the beginning with
getting everything booted up and all the
cameras to wake up but then and there
were their creative limitations you know
when it's just the three of us there I'm
so appreciative to the extended team and
I mean you can you'll be able to see the
difference in in this week's episodes
and again it's still just three of them
we're gonna go to five as soon as we can
but that's not this week as you're
listening to this
fresh but yeah it was it was great to be
in the space and you know afterward the
thing that I slacked out to the team and
that I was reflecting it's funny because
as I was driving home yesterday having
recorded the episodes in the studio I
started listening to the audio book
because I'm so hooked on this story I
just want to keep going but then I was
like you know what I'm gonna pause this
and I'm gonna reflect on what happened
today and so on the ride home which was
a lot shorter because a nobody on the
freeway still I just took that time just
to stop and celebrate the fact that we
did it I mean so by the time I got home
I was able to convey what I would
appreciate it myself to the team and
that was it was the experience of being
behind the desk and for us to like be in
the same space and to make the show and
it was the most normal that I felt since
being in quarantine
I mean you it's it was just it was
refreshing
it was relieving it was like a sigh of
relief to drive into work to do and to
do it and then drive to drive back home
it felt so like it used to be and then
when I got home you know I entered back
into a space where no one else was
feeling that and we were navigating all
the challenges of the accumulation of
isolation and frustration and how that
all that comes out sideways but I had
more in my tank than I've had in a
really long time because just of a sense
of normalcy it's so powerful it's funny
it's funny you talk about that
transition from basically going to work
for the first time I mean we've been
working but the whole idea of going into
the studio and getting back into that
rhythm of like I'm at this space where
it is designated as a place where I do
my job
and then I come back to my home and I
was I was in the same place I was
feeling really good I was like I was so
I was very proud of our team you know
they show us all the time how good they
are what they do and how they facilitate
what we're best at doing they do what
they're best at so that we can do what
we're best at and it mean it works right
mm-hmm and yesterday even though we had
doubts about this process like what is
it gonna be like for just the three of
us to be in there and all that it'd be
remote well they figured it out and it
worked and then we could have a good
time which is the key to us making a
good show is us having a good time so I
was thinking the same thing and then I
got home and we had experimented with
this you know we've had trouble getting
Shepard to do his schoolwork without
constant interference or inter you know
intervening and so me and she ever had a
conversation last week where we were
like we're gonna try something new even
though this is like the last week of
school or the last two weeks of school I
was like we're gonna try something just
see if we can get this you know we're
gonna give you the opportunity to
basically set your schedule and get your
work done and we're gonna check in at
the end of the day and what we're trying
to do is we're trying to instill or
establish trust with you so that then
you can have freedom right because no
one is enjoying this constant argument
about hey are you doing your work you do
in your work and this is especially
difficult for Jessi because she's the
one who I'm over here at the creative
house or whatever and she's dealing with
it constantly so you know I get home and
it's like first of all I'm gonna grill
some tuna steaks on the grill that was
my that was my job for dinner but I was
also gonna check in on Shepherd and
checking on Shepherd and then like he
kinda did some stuff but then he didn't
fully do it and there was an argument
that broke out about that and then there
was an argument that broke out with with
Locke account even more what it was we I
was in the kitchen and Jessi was cutting
something
a pair of scissors and then I was
walking and she turned around with the
scissors and I bumped into her no one
was hurt but then she thought was my
fault I thought it was her fault were
yelling at each other and she's got the
pair of scissors guys and so basically
with every family member with the
exception of Barbara I don't think
Barbara did anything to piss me off
she rarely does it it was like I had
gone from this place where everyone was
doing exactly what I needed them to do
in order to make my life easier
yeah to a place where no one was doing
anything they made my life easy it
wasn't about me in my life being easy it
was about being a part of this family
where everybody's got their own needs
everybody's got their own stuff that
they're dealing with and we're all tired
of each other and it was just like I
went from zero to 11 just all of a
sudden and then after dinner jesse was
like do you she said do you want to go
sleep at the creative house tonight and
see that bed that I put in there that
you think give me a hard time about what
she was like there is a there is a bed
yeah I was like oh yeah it's a child's
bed do I look like a child it's not a
child but it's a twin bed so did you
sleep on it how did it feel well I
didn't sleep on it I said I'm not gonna
do that
I said you know I just need a little
time to myself
I guess because she's giving it to me
and I didn't I so I took my really long
you know four and a half mile walk and
then you sat on the steps and weep was
that yesterday mmm yes last night and
well I'll have to say the word
I don't I don't have I mean I'm just
saying I relate to what you're saying
this whole Inn and all I can do is be
grateful for because you know not
everybody has that not everybody has
most people and I'm not saying we don't
have frustrations at work from time to
time but you know it's it's an
exceptional thing to be like man they
they just did all this stuff for us and
that's the level of ownership I think
that's the thing that is so impressive
with so many members of our team is that
they're like this is this isn't just
rhettandlink singh this is our thing and
we're gonna do it well like we're gonna
do it in an excellent way and it just
makes it it makes it fun you know yeah
and I mean we've so many people have it
so difficult I mean some of you people
don't even have jobs to go to so it's
you know a lot of people you know I want
to I want to acknowledge that and you
know just if there's any way to sim from
my experience I guess the the
encouragement and I don't know if
there's much to it is if there's a way
to if there's not normal in your life is
there's a way to simulate it you know I
don't even know what that what that
would mean it even just a glimpse of it
for a few minutes
helps so much okay before we get into
the questions let's make a little plug
let's we action we'd like to groom
ourselves and like a cut like a couple
of chimpanzees we don't groom each other
we grew myself and we have grooming
products available at mythical calm
because these link holding them right
there we've got mythical pomade for all
your hair needs I'm basically out I
gotta get some more look at your hair
she's got too long oh I'm wearing a hand
in more of it we're gonna head a dick is
too long yeah there's that and mythical
lip balm Lynx peculiarly perfect peanut
butter peppermint flavor is available
along with rets wooden berries I think
we still have some of that this
particular one it says links on it
because that's on the label but then it
also has a a printed label that says
link because it's yours and it's yours
is mine and it's mine that's right this
came from the office where I think it
was in my my makeup bag my god
Graham yourself people people always say
that they're pleasantly surprised
because they think it's just some sort
of gimmick that we sell lip balm but
I'll put this lip balm up against
anybody's lip balm you will be
pleasantly surprised because it's
peculiarly perfect get it in a two pack
mythical calm okay let's start with a
question from Michelle miss Belvedere on
the Twitter mm-hmm what's your most
irrational fear I am oddly afraid of
wind turbines and other large things and
bounce wind turbines wind turbine how do
you say that she told me say windmill
like the ones out going out to Palm
Springs the huge windmills those up yeah
I mean you drive by those on the on the
freeway if you're going out to Palm
Springs that's remember the first time I
drove out to Palm Springs it was when we
were going to we were going to the the
the wrestlers reality house I can't
remember what it was called religions of
legends house they had a reality show
and they brought us in as guest judges
cuz because the wrestlers divided up
into two teams and made uh local
commercials we got to meet rowdy roddy
piper who's may he rest in peace Mean
Gene may he rest in peace Mean Gene cool
guy that guy man you just got a sense
this guy was full of stories I wish I
wish we could have hung out with him
more Hillbilly Jim you know hacksaw that
wasn't whose I want to Christie's
favorites for some reason but I remember
that was the first time we went out we
went to Palm Springs and we and they
they put us in a it wasn't a limo it was
a car we both
in the backseat is I'm like Town Car and
I was like crap
look at those windmills you remember
that that's the first time I'd ever seen
him probably you too I don't remember
the moment and specifically but yeah
maybe we saw someone we traveled across
the country for the mythical roadtrip
but this this one left the most
indelible impression and I do relate to
Michelle I sense a feel I have a
clarifying questions I can use it
because I first of all they're much
bigger than you understand or can
appreciate until you get right next to
them I mean even like they cuz they look
like they're just sort of moving like
this yeah but if you were to get up
there and there's a reason that you know
if a bird flies into one it's like
getting hit it's like a golf ball with a
baseball bat or worse oh gosh
oh I mean these things are a lot they're
so going so fast they're just so big it
doesn't look like yeah I can imagine if
I was right next to it having a sense of
awe inspiring fear you can take a tour
we should go decisions looking at on
holes it's just like looking at a whole
hillside of them is scary I think we
don't listen I don't we don't have to
analyze Michelle's fears she's really
asking us what is our irrational fear I
think you know my what's yours what's
your easier as Heights I don't I don't
know what yours is actually I think I
got a few I mean I don't know if height
height is an irrational fear there are
certain situations in which it's very
rational yeah to be scared of heights
I'm scared of heights that are
associated I'm scared of heights Plus no
hand holds does that make sense like
like a railing like your wife sent us
that video at our group chat of those
people in some tourist attraction where
you have to like walk on these weird
things that are like looked like a mile
high and one of them is like was like
planks that were on - what are those
metal why what metal wires cables why
I'm ever forgetting the word both but
one
and you had a jumper [ __ ] trip one of
them is like a trapeze where it's just a
plank and two ropes and you have to like
swings and you have to go to the next
one now I'm not saying I'd be okay with
this but I would be much more okay with
that one like cuz I've got something to
hold on to then the second one which is
just the cables and the planks
and you just got to go to the next place
like and they were something about being
took I haven't give that out of the next
plank but then after a couple of those
the planks started to get further apart
so you had to jump and it was like
freaking Mario yeah and you you're
tethered you're strapped in tethered but
you there's nothing to hold on to so you
just stand in there well and it's and
it's loose like tethered but it's you
forget about it knows there's full slack
so you don't feel any protective
measures so that's one but the one that
my wife makes fun of me all the time for
is my fear of bats yeah I remember the
being in the hot tub story where the
bats kept swooping death so yeah I mean
in most places in the United States
because I mean I'm saying most places
because it happens in California and it
happened in North Carolina like once
dusk comes around you start seeing the
air light is that a bird flying
erratically like no that's a bat it's a
bat and he's flying in weird directions
and swooping swooping down like and
getting really close to your head right
and I told you the story of what
happened to Heather Dinklage growing up
where we were outside and a bat freaking
landed in her hair bitter on the neck
what at least she said that it bit her
on the neck but I think it may just got
caught in her hair or something might
have clawed her I got claws man in my
mind at one point was all the bats will
never actually come in contact with you
because they got like sonar you know
what I'm saying they're not gonna
they're not actually gonna come in
contact with you they're gonna get close
to you no no not not if Heather Dinklage
is any is any indication indicate well
that's the word I'm looking for
you've never been touched by a bat
though but you but you fear it's never
touched a bet okay but you'll write in
the back you're a
- bees - like it's a flying around I'm
afraid of a flying bat I'm not if you
were to hand me a bat and to pet no
problem maybe even cute it's a mouse
with wings but the flying and the
potential for the bike and the rabies so
what happened with with the situation
with Jessie that you're talking about is
I got out of the hot tub and I was
drying off and they had been swooping
over the hot tub the whole time that we
were in there but one came right at me
as I'm drying off and I just fell to the
ground because I had nowhere to go I
couldn't go under the water like I
normally would do so I just fell
completely back and Jesse never let me
live that down and I'm like what you
don't know if I had there Dinklage you
weren't there but you weren't there
either yeah she told us about it but I
mean she was my neighbor and you'll that
you'll fall flat for a bee man you know
like bees you if you just want a bee
it's gonna it's gonna increase the
chances of a singing you that's my
belief
my my experience with a bee is if you
just still and I ain't even talk about
when I had 10,000 of them on my face and
trying to go into my eyeballs in my nose
holes and my mouth hole I'm telling this
like normal walking the dog and you hear
a bunch of buzzing in a particular
blooming tree and there's like beef
coming around you and like if you're
still they'll leave you alone they're
like oh you're not nectar right yeah I
have to have a difficult time relaxing
because it is different but I think it's
based on the fact that I have had a bee
in my hand as a kid that bit me I hope
you don't even stung me I mean I know
that you're mostly right that they
usually won't do that but especially if
you don't know that they're there and
there's like one under your arm and you
reach there you can get stung man
there's a potential to get stung I know
that's not the end of the world but I
just don't like getting stung so I would
say it increases that chance of getting
stung
it's the lose barrier to be around you
man well you know I'm gonna be scared of
something
well my choice is blood flow and you
know this
I mean everybody knows us at this point
I mean people have a fear of blood and I
I do too I mean I you know I cut myself
over the the tried and true story
opening the Barbie on Christmas morning
at my father-in-law's house with his
knife and I I ran to the kitchen next
thing I know I'm coming to from fainting
in and looking up and I'm in my
father-in-law's arms at the sink that
was embarrassing
I like you said I've never lived that
down but I have this I just get afraid
when we when I think about blood flow
and I actually looked that up before
this I'm like fear of blood circulation
and I couldn't find anything all I could
find was just fear of blood and you know
people talk about the theories of
fainting the evolutionary theories of
fainting are that like if you faint
you're basically it's your body playing
dead so then whatever scared the crap
out of you like the impending death was
circumvented by fainting so then you're
like playing possum and you don't get
killed and then you pass along your
genes which give a proclivity towards
fainting it also you also say that when
you when you faint like your your your
blood pressure goes down in your your
blood pools in your legs that's why
you're supposed to put your head between
your knees so that you can get blood to
like pull in your head so you don't
faint but the theory there is if you
have an injury and you are bleeding so
like if you see yourself bleeding and
you faint at the at your father-in-law's
kitchen sink well you start bleeding you
study don't bleed as much you don't
bleed out because it's it's slowed down
of course it's a little pesky when
you're not alert and you can't treat
yourself but if other people are there
well question though
so we're specifically with the fear of
blood flow because okay while I
acknowledge that fear of bats or fear of
bees is to the level that I exercise it
is irrational but there is a rational
element to it that I'm like well I don't
want to get stung or I don't want to get
bit right yeah I figure a blood flow
what do you what is the specific fear
that you're they worth what's the route
where does it go it's interesting
because yeah I mean I should be afraid
of my blood not flowing oh my gosh I
don't think my Bloods moving I'm gonna
if it wasn't flowing I don't think you
could even process that thought I know I
think but blood flow is rational thing
to be acquired for thought exactly so I
shouldn't be afraid of the thing that is
necessary to continue living but it
makes me queasy
like if I have to get my blood drawn I
tell them now I thought hey I I could
faint I'm going I would like to lay down
before you do this because I don't want
to be that good that but I don't want to
have a different I don't take your blood
taken oh yeah that's somebody literally
tapping into a vein which I don't like I
mean and I've gotten close to fainting
in that situation I think that's a
pretty normal thing but you're but
there's no rationale I think about well
yeah there is some rationale to the
injury because it's like like like I
said like I said but if somebody sticks
what an intense are sucking out your
life force you should be afraid of that
I think it's just the the direct
association like if I can feel the blood
pumping through my veins I can think of
it coming out of the veins I can think
of it spilling every but you don't like
to feel like if you were to feel like if
you look if I look at my wrist right
here I can see a little I can see the
heartbeat a little bit like that grosses
you out currently right now it is
grossing me out it's making me feel a
little weak and then you only on a look
yeah but you also were afraid of your
rib that wouldn't come to the part so no
but I'm saying that it doesn't have to I
want to know what's have to come to the
party because here listen to this
because you the thing we haven't talked
about it is what the only times in my
life that I've fainted is when I've
gotten bad medical news right
so the notorious story is when I first
time I found out that I had herniated
discs when I had convinced my
stuff that I didn't have herniated discs
and I'd also convinced myself that
herniated discs meant that life was over
as I knew it and that I was gonna
basically be incapable of doing anything
athletic for the rest of my life which
is not true but when I got that news I
been the doctor left the the doctor's
office I heard a boom a bang and I was
like oh man something happened in the
office behind me and then I realized
that I was laying up against the wall
and I had fallen it awful not falling
off but I was sitting on the table and
falling back to the wall I fainted it I
had caused the boom and then because I
was sitting there contemplating that my
fate
yeah and then the doctor comes back in
and I didn't tell him of course because
I wasn't there for fainting I was there
for my back I'm not gonna tell the back
doctor hey man I got a fainting problem
too slamming side against the wall like
that and then when I hurt my knee
you know skiing this year when we were
talking about it at the dinner table I
started feeling like I was gonna think
because again I was thinking about what
was this mean what does this mean for my
future you know there's a rationale well
but it's a rationale but it's based on a
little threat of rationality but then it
becomes irrational it's based on logic
it's based on taking something to like
it's it's scary extent yeah I don't I
don't his are based on something the
basically some logic Lily it's hard for
me to believe but she swears up and down
that she has a phobia of whales and I
just I'm like okay they're huge you've
never had an encounter with a whale I
don't understand why you're afraid of
whales just from watching Nemo or
something as a baby as a kid but I don't
know why it I mean I can only guess that
circulation makes me uncomfortable
because if something goes wrong
circulation leads to leads to gushing
and that's that that's a lot of people
are afraid of that it's just an
association maybe
maybe this is it there are times when
I'm just sitting there and I start
thinking about the fact that I have a
body yeah
and then I started thinking about what
that body is and what it looks like and
like I'm like oh crap there's just like
there's just like stuff inside of me
that's soft and doing things and it's
responsible for things and I'm not aware
of it and it's just happening and the
day that it stops happening I stop
happening and that I will get close to
inducing a panic attack if I think about
that enough you just started a me
sometimes you just think about the
fragility of humanity you just you just
look at this stuff and you're like I
could just take a metal thing and just
stick it into this hand and it would
just go right through it
you know what I mean like yeah gradual
they're just gooey stuff but there's
people who I mean surgeons but lots of
different types of people come to grips
of this in you the treatment for a lot
of phobias is exposure therapy which you
know they can you know they look at
blood as just okay this is a this is
just something that happens it's a
physical thing that happens and if the
pain associated with injuries and like
guts being spilled out this is all the
stuff that I've studying and then I
understand being inside of people and
mushy is now outside and we got to get
it back inside you know it's very I can
see how yeah over time that would become
yeah I'm sure it Lots people would go to
medical school not because they have a
you know they're impervious to that
stuff is because you know their parents
want them to be a doctor and then by the
time they're done with medical school
they they're impervious but in college
well yep definitely my mom told me in
like the studies that she did that like
they had to work with cadavers and
there's like at that point people are
like fainting left and right like
there's certain people when you get to
that point when you're gonna touch a
dead body and you just start working
with it that you know that's a big
that's a big test but you know you I
in college I did exposure therapy twice
a week we would go donate plasma they
would shove a huge freakin needle like a
pipe needle in in in you vein in your
arm and they would suck out your blood
run it through a machine get the plasma
out and then they would pump the blood
back in through the same vein and it
would it would go through cycles and if
you wanted to do it quicker you'd like
really get your get your hand pies still
don't understand how did I was there
well I mean we've got we've discussed
before I mean one of the reasons is
because of one of the nurses April was
hot you know the main reason if she was
there it was worth whatever she was
gonna do the main reason was the the
thing I'm most afraid of he's going
broke I'ma be honest I've always had
this fear of going broke in like and you
got $20 $40 cash for and it was so it
redeemed it and I did get more
comfortable with it but every time they
would put the needle in especially
because sometimes and they would miss
all right here's a warning guys
you know if you're like me you need to
be seated put your head in between your
knees because the worst thing that would
happen is they would put the needle into
the vein and then they would it was they
would call it something but then they
would keep going and they would puncture
both sides of it see how I'm even
getting you and then yeah I hate it
good because then you don't understand
how I was feeling into your arm and you
you you come out with a huge bruise
because they would they would I don't
know that I can't remember what the word
they would use this and then they'd have
to pull the needle back and thread it
into the vein oh my gosh the fact that I
can't even talks about it that makes me
queasy I don't I don't think that's
irrational III think that there's a
reason to be scared of it and I can
endure that yet after stopping the
plasma donation I like junior year or
something senior year I mean I still
have the scars but I'm queasy now about
it what if I told that story fainted in
the middle of a podcast that would be
sensational
but don't mean don't you feel and you're
about to start fading her
happen immediately I hot there's a good
like 15 to 20 second sort of onset for
me it's next question it's slightly
different slightly different note from
Adam be grim I don't know if that is a
real name or a pseudonym how do you
pronounce I'm gonna have to pronounce it
by asking these questions yeah that's it
washes your sauce I think this is the
for in the history of your biscuits this
may be the first question that in
reading the question we've answered it
how do you pronounce Worcestershire
selves know you okay you just made up a
pronunciation I I know there's people
who say it that way I say whoosh
Worcestershire Worcestershire but I
think it's Worcestershire Worcestershire
it's forgot Shire on the end it's not
sheer yeah I know but you had
pronunciation adapts over time I know
that it's that this is I guess this has
got to be related to a district in
England that's actually or Chester
Worcestershire warchest are shyer or
Chester's higher and I don't know how
first of all let's just put it into a
pronunciation thing here that's that's
the key we got to do that I don't trust
these pronunciation things these are
just people who want to get ad revenue
on YouTube so they make videos where a
bot says something your rights don't
you're right talk have you ever listened
to a GPS it gets the street names wrong
all the time but it's a starting point
it's a point of reference here we go
Worcestershire Worcestershire first of
all in in England they don't say York
Shire there's a Yorkshire it's a Shire
Yorkshire so it's all you know they put
that on the end of it but they always
say sure so you don't need to say shy
washer washer again Wooster
what's the sure like what's the sure but
there's not a T that early next question
Daphne at golden underscore army asks
is ignorant really bliss oh we gonna get
philosophical here or is this practical
how do you want how you want to approach
this you know both Jessie my wife and I
are you know there are people who are
sort of news junkies right so like
everyday they got to find out what's
going on if something happened they're
gonna know we're both like that but
there's just you know there's just a
bunch of [ __ ] going on all the time
right I mean and so that's why the the
some good news which ironically has sold
the vehicle that's why that was such a
good idea from John Krasinski's I say
his name woosh because it you know
because the whole idea that is that we
were just bombarded with bad news so I
was having a conversation with my
therapist about how one of the things
that I've noticed in being home a whole
lot more and not being at work and gone
during the day but being at home and
actually seen Jessie a lot more than
normal
is that Jessie tends to get more so than
me
she'll read about something in the news
and it will anger her right she'll get
mad out of a sense of you know it might
be a sense of justice it's often a sense
of justice where is this a sense of
being annoyed with people for being
idiots about something and she needs to
somebody to talk to about that and so
that person when I'm home is me and so I
was talking about therapist and saying
I'm kind of realizing that you know
first of all we always have a lot going
on but like as things begin to sort of
move back to more of a normal place and
we're figuring out how to get all the
stuff done that we need to get done the
stuff that you see like this but also
the stuff that we're working on that may
never see the light of day
I start feeling a sense of being
overwhelmed and I started realizing that
if a certain percentage of my
interactions with her were based on her
relatable [ __ ] that happened in the
world a lot of times for me when I hear
about somebody who did something stupid
or something wrong that happened I
immediately add it to my big bag of
things that I'm supposed to figure out
right so that's why occasionally I'll
write one of these medium pieces about
some issue right and it's because my
personality is is if you give me this
information I feel responsible for
having an opinion about it and then
sometimes that responsibility for having
an opinion because of my platform
translates into you have to say
something about this like it is your
responsibility to speak your perspective
on this and that's probably based on you
know narcissism and thinking that my
perspectives important whatever but it's
not it is based on my sense of justice
and feeling like I need to say something
right but what what I was realizing is
that she's telling me about something
that the president said or something
that happened and it's just adding to
this bag of stuff that I feel like I
have to process and I told my therapist
I feel like for this month of that we're
moving into June I'm gonna kind of take
a news fast and not feel like I have to
be informed about every single thing
that's happening with the virus or every
single thing that the president is
saying or doing like just sort of for a
second turn that faucet off and see how
it affects my personal health and
perspective because a lot of times even
before even when I get up in the morning
and I'm about to meditate if I've gone
on Twitter and I've seen the latest
[ __ ] thing I take that into that
process and it's very difficult to let
go of yeah so in that sense what I'm
getting at an answer to this question
is I feel like to a certain degree
ignorance is bliss yeah I mean I I think
it's clear in the situation that the the
key is moderation I mean welcome to my
world
you know I I err on the opposite side of
just not being more ignorant about
things that are happening I mean when
you talk about news especially it's like
it gives to me in a different way
because I feel like I I think you have
this sense of like because there's
something that you can do whether it's
the fact that we have a platform of the
fact that you you enjoy writing and
piecing things together so there you do
have an outlet to to weigh in on these
things
I actually feel personally because that
I I don't have that same experience I I
feel a frustration and kind of a
helplessness when those things happen
and it's so it's not a pressure to to
engage it's a it's a frustration that I
just don't feel like I'm equipped to do
that I feel that sometimes I think but
then if I get bombarded with a with a
lot of things I have this palpable sense
of capacity you know everything you know
you talk about things accumulating and
it just kind of builds up a book to me
it's it's it's not a pressure it's a I
just get buried underneath it and I feel
like I can't do the things that I want
that I do need to devote my energy and
attention to and to a fault right so
there are times when there's certain
things in the news that I do need to
know about and at least be exposed to
may I don't have to have an opinion that
then I would publicly like lay into
somebody about it but it is it's it's
good and it's healthy to to understand
what's happening out there again to just
stay on the news front
so you know I tried to like I'll listen
to up first which is like a very quick
like the the headlines you know it just
kind of takes you through the headlines
and then it's you move on but I'm not
reading these articles and like getting
really deep in a lot of things so that's
been my correction is I need to be a
little bit more I need to be a little
less ignorant about things because yes
it's I think it it does simplify my life
and it allow it gives me the capacity to
invest in the things I need to invest in
but there's some things that come in
sideways if you didn't anticipate that
that you need to be informed by and so
I've made some adjustments on that level
but in this case if I try not to get too
deep in it because wealth health
personality base right
it's very personality based for instance
okay those of you who follow me on
Instagram or Twitter know that first of
all I'm incredibly sporadic and
sometimes I'll just go on a run for a
few days or a few weeks where I'm pretty
active on those platforms and it's
usually an indication that I don't we
don't have a project that's taking a lot
of bulk time and at the very beginning
of quarantine we had a lot of time all
of a sudden because our lives were
turned upside down and our business was
turned upside down and then you know I
get really frustrated when I just see
people spouting off things that aren't
true and there's been so much
misinformation around kovat and it's
like people just fall into two camps and
and they don't it's like everything has
become political right and so I enlisted
I'm no authority and I try to say that
over and over again I'm just a dude
who's interested in this stuff who has a
platform who makes a living on YouTube
so I'm definitely not an authority on
any of this but I like to point and sort
of elevate voices that are
two voices that are authorities and you
know I went through this phase where I
was kind of like engaging I was posting
something and that people would like
have questions about it or be critical
of it and I would personally engage and
you may notice why I haven't been doing
that for the past few weeks and it's
largely I mean there's a number of
reasons one is we are busy with other
things there's a couple of things that
are taking more like bulk pieces of my
time more attention there's also a sense
of hopelessness you know there's this
sense that like there are just some
people who are so committed to they're
just dug in in their trench so deeply
that nothing that you can say no fact
that you can point them to is going to
change anything and so there just
becomes the sense of hopelessness and so
I've kind of backed off that and then
the thing I'm adding to it is well I
also don't even want to really know
what's happening in the news for a
little bit just for a moment personal
health but I am very grateful to the
people who day by day especially those
people who are thora T's on these issues
and there are a few people I follow on
Twitter who are like a daily briefing
about kovat and here's the latest you
know or you've you've got certain
websites like Snopes that are committed
to you know setting the record straight
on all these issues and they're
constantly having to deal with
misinformation
I just am very grateful to those people
who are in the trenches and fighting
that battle and trying to get you know
fight this information and get the right
information out but I just I can't do it
it's just not it's not healthy to do it
but like you said there are some things
you know like what happened with am on
Arbor II or what happened very when
we're recording this just happened two
days ago two days ago in Minneapolis
would George Floyd yeah and you know out
I'll put something on Instagram or
Twitter about that just to acknowledge
that you know again I want to elevate
those those voices and I want to bring
attention to something with my platform
I'm not trying to pontificate or just
come in and try to say something about
it I'm just more like this is a thing
that you should know about
so the like you said there's a balance
because I don't want to completely
detach because there there's so much
injustice and there's so much
misinformation that's constantly just
happening that if you have a platform I
feel like you've got to be engaged on
some level or if I mean not even a
platform I I think for me it's that like
I know we're we're very fortunate
hashtag blessed you know in in so many
ways and we're privileged right and it's
and it's not necessarily just and it's
so it's you know I can live in this
bubble of of ignorance and be blissful
and it's in this and if you take that
too too far it's I just I don't want to
be that person and it's just not it's
just not right to say okay as long as
I'm happy then that I'm good you know
it's that's very it's already self
centered now it to take that to an
extreme right but you also have to know
what your limits are and I think that's
what we're talking about so it's not I'm
gonna check out and I'm gonna do
whatever it takes for me to be happy you
know it's not just we I don't want my
actions to just be about my happiness or
just the people that I love the most
because I know them and I'm or I'm
related to them you know it's like you
wanna well there's a way to get my still
extend myself and that starts with being
informed and there's a way to be in for
a fight every battle but if you're not
fighting any battles at least I I don't
I don't feel like that's the right
choice for me well and there's a way to
be informed that doesn't take all your
time like you're saying I I think you
know one of the things that helps me and
I'm not you know I'm not organized I'm
but I am very like goal-oriented task
driven and one of the things that helps
me we're just getting
all the things that I do done is like
okay here's the day this is what I'm
gonna actually I'd like to get this much
of this thing done and I'd like to get
this much of this thing done I kind of
got a vision for what that day's gonna
look like and then I kind of do it and I
cut myself some slack if I don't quite
get there but at least I kind of know
where I'm gonna go and then when it
comes to stuff like social media even if
you're going on to Twitter with the
intention of figuring out what's going
on in the world is there any news that I
need to know about being foreign about
something it's one thing to set it's one
thing to just basically constantly go
back in there every time you get a
little bit bored and then when you learn
about an issue kind of go down that
rabbit hole and start arguing with
somebody on the internet about it or
finding every perspective on it and then
the next thing you know you spent two
hours on your phone and you've
accomplished nothing that's one thing
and then it's another thing to be like I
want to know about this it's like with a
you know I I kind of checked out
yesterday didn't pay attention to much
stuff that's it I said another thing I
didn't mention when I got home all that
stuff happened with my kids and my wife
but in the middle of all that I stepped
outside and went on Twitter and that's
when I saw the George Floyd video and I
got very angry yeah I just was I was so
angry about that and and then now of
course all I did was just posted I think
oh this morning I actually just posted a
picture of him on my Instagram and it's
like I'm sure I could do more but a and
I didn't find out about it until this
morning when I had my slot where I was
like catching up on the news yeah um in
it you know it's I wouldn't have wanted
to never have known about it you know
and for it to impact me the way that it
did this morning because it certainly
did and does but
it didn't last night because I set up
parameters and there were you know there
were things I was invested in last night
when my family I think we can leave it
at that right I think I want I wanted to
switch gears to one more question cat at
jia ling ster okay you can use my
picture if you want to could a snake
physically wear clothes you know what i
just want to just want to highlight the
video version of this with our answer to
this question and share with you that
jenna put a scarf on craig who she's
been taken care of at her home
craig the snake has a scarf and he's
wearing it constantly because did Jenna
make it for him I think she's actually
wearing it he's wearing to clarify he's
not wearing it constantly that would
probably be some form of animal abuse
but he did wear it for a picture and she
didn't make it I know I was any seemed
to enjoy it as much as you can tell
whether a reptile is enjoying something
so yeah a snake can wear at least a
scarf I would think that a that a snake
could wear a shirt which would just be
like a tube sock but I don't think they
necessarily need it I don't think they
need it you ready for a wreck yeah baby
wreck baby one two three four I'm gonna
give another reddit wreck I follow the
thread movie details I think I may have
mentioned this before because I'm into
it again it's just a little escape from
it you you can you can read this thread
and like here's a recent one in Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom you know
one of my favs John Williams gave short
round you know the kid who was with Indy
his own hero theme music any time he is
in action the theme plays just like
Indies theme place for him so and there
there's um there's lots of movie details
you can get it to like Jack Black was in
Waterworld what yeah
I saw that one a few a few times back
yeah if you just if you just search Jack
Black water that's crazy he appears as a
smoking pilot uh-huh crazy like oh yeah
I mean I actually don't know if that's
true but you know no I see it there it
is see movie details reddit thread
follow that it can remind you of movies
that you need to watch again or watch
for the first time in it as you're
watching movies if you want to
contribute to the thread it gives you
something to think about it's like hey
it's a little something I noticed it
kind of raises the bar on how
intentionally you watch your movies so
check it out if you're on Reddit movie
detail thanks again for all your
questions they spark some some good
discussions discussions that we didn't
even know that we needed to have oh so I
personally I really like these episodes
where that are driven by the mythical
beasts questions because I think we like
I said we'd get into some things that we
wouldn't otherwise intend to get into so
I want to do more of these follow us on
Twitter whenever we put those prompts
out there and as always use hashtag ear
biscuits in order to continue this
conversation weigh in on any aspect of
that you want to and we'll talk also let
us know let us know using hashtag your
biscuits what your how you feeling about
these these these episodes where we
answer your questions because I want to
know all right next week to watch more
ear biscuits click on the playlist on
the right to watch the previous episode
of your biscuits click on the playlist
to the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]